everything goes back to mindset so like
spend a lot of time strengthening at it
because it's the only thing that will
ensure that you don't break when you
have bad months or recessions come and
everything else welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host Tisha mizzouz and
on this week's episode I was joined by
James Blackwell Skilling a business is
like the scariest thing you'll ever do
in your life and it's going to put you
in places of being extremely
uncomfortable and you have to be
comfortable being uncomfortable now you
may have seen one of his ads at some
point pop up on your LinkedIn James has
gone on a journey where he's scaled his
recruitment business to be doing seven
figures a year and he is very detached
from that business he's not working in
the business he is always working on the
business so he's ended up going on this
journey where he's now built a education
company called the agency blueprint so
he helps recruitment entrepreneurs
typically people that have their own
recruitment business who are stuck on
that 5 to 10 50 15 grand a month hamster
will we break down how you can go about
using virtual resources to do your
candidate sourcing to do your lead
management and for those of you that are
interested in potentially working with
James and his team use the link in the
show notes to booking a call with his
team and you're going to get looked
after because you've come through the
podcast enjoy it into the episode
James welcome back to the podcast
thank you for having me Hisham
I was just saying we uh did this remote
two years ago
covert times
and hopefully
I've improved my interviewing skills
no like I said you were good interviewer
so don't be too harsh on yourself but
I'm looking forward to uh today's
episode because I know A lot's changed
since the last two years especially in
uh the recruitment space and and also my
businesses so happy to share some wisdom
where I can
exactly so I think purpose of of today
is like was excited to get Jones back is
I see the content you put out I get hit
by your LinkedIn ads I'll get your
emails because I'm always curious to
learn on how other people are doing what
they're doing
so I think other people that listen to
this podcast might have experienced the
same some of the ads you might have seen
they might even be getting your emails
so I think what I'm really excited to do
today is really just get into the
nitty-gritty of how you actually help
people and what that actually looks like
in terms of the things that you find
yourself uh you teach people the systems
of processes so we're going to really
focus on that but I thought just to
start like why don't you just tell us
give us the the high level details of
like your own recruitment business where
it is today
um talk to us about you know what it did
revenue-wise last year or however do
your financial year might have been uh
just gone what you ended up GP wise how
many people you have in the business
because I think what's really important
that people know is with what you do
you're walking the walk and I think
that's important when you're in the
education business so let's just start
there give us the details of where
Ronald James is today and then we're
going to go into the agency blueprint
and this journey that you've been on
over the last couple of years sure
sounds good so so yeah so those that
maybe didn't watch the last episode just
to give you a quick uh synopsis of my
recruitment agency and then agency
blueprint so I founded Ronald James
almost a decade ago so I think it's like
over eight years now and that's really
transformed over those years so I think
um now to this day
um it is pretty much self-managing
without me so now I live in Dubai I
manage that team remotely from slack and
zoom and obviously I've got a good team
and a good team culture in place in a
physical office in Newcastle in the UK
and um yeah so so the businesses has
been gone from Stanford strength I think
the difference between what I've done
with Ronald James over the probably the
last two years it's pretty much stayed
the same in terms of uh performance but
also knowing that it revolves zero of my
time
so I think the big thing say for
instance last year performance uh we did
just over 1.5 million in terms of
Revenue that's pretty much mostly all
perm Revenue fees and uh very high
profit margins between 40 50 and I think
that comes down to just having solid
systems in place over the years really
good exclusive and some retained clients
and a really good team uh in terms of
how we developed the remote sourcing
team so that really allowed us to skill
with uh do more placements without
having more Recruiters in the seats if
that makes sense so so we have a small
team around about 11 12 employees at the
time we're recording this and that's a
mixture between in the office hybrid and
remote so some people work in the office
maybe one two days a week some three
days a week some fully remote uh in
different places around the world
and they're all full-time employees of
Ronald James yeah
and it's all Palm that you've that
you've typically done then yeah I mean
look we've probably done uh maybe 10 15
now and again as as contract for some of
our best clients that need some uh
contract resource but um yeah we've
predominantly done perm just because
when I started as a recruiter
what many many years ago maybe 15 years
ago 14 years ago I've always done
permanent recruitment so uh I I prefer
just because it's cleaner easier and uh
it's a lot easier to do that while
stepping away from the business day of
the day
and it's Tech that you do and is it is
it like fairly Niche do you mainly do
business in the UK do you do other stuff
in the in the US Europe
yeah good question so we we focus
predominantly in the north east of
England uh so that's pretty much our
whatever called bread and butter with
the biggest digital and Tech recruitment
agency in the Northeast in terms of the
placements made the clients that we got
on our books and clients that we've
serviced and then we've also relaunched
um Boston in the us because we just
hired a quite a really good senior
recruiter that's going to really build
out that market uh back in Boston so we
were doing that and then we stopped and
then we're back into the US market as
well
okay so 1.5 million last year 11 to 12
full-time employees about 450 profit
margins and then obviously this is why
where I wanted to start that's sort of
what your recruitment business looks
like and then you can tell us but
obviously what I put down here in terms
of what you now do you've got two
products you've got your recruiter
accelerator which is all centered around
helping recruitment entrepreneurs
recruitment business owners scale their
business to six and seven figures which
you've done for yourself and and you're
doing and then the other element is you
have an elite Mastermind for those
people that really wanna take uh their
earning potential seriously and want to
uh you know take their business to a
million plus yeah correct so that's a
different business called the agency
blueprint so that's uh probably been my
main focus over the last
um definitely the last three years has
been transcending into uh teaching
others exactly what I replicate in my
agency and really really helping them
build out the system's Automation and
the remote team so they can scale up to
seven figures without having to work
harder as such so uh that's been uh yeah
the focus on the other business we've
got two products for that we could
accelerator so that's pretty much
helping anyone from zero to 10 20K a
month uh that want to scale up and
implement the the foundations which
we'll probably dive into today around
why I think we could a lot of
recruitment agency owners uh don't
really reverse engineer things back to
First principles and build out the
systems thinking from day one and then
for those that want to actually scale to
seven figures we we have a elite
Mastermind so I do live events in Dubai
us the UK and a lot more closer
specialized support from me and my team
uh yeah and then I've got other
companies that I've invested in as well
so I've got two other companies that
I've invested in I've got a SAS company
that just started and investments in
property commercial residential and yeah
that's been pretty much the growth so
far
and you've uh and you obviously in
preparing for this you've told me sort
of for anyone listening this has ended
up being like the real like sweet spot
of people that you've ended up helping
you might be someone that is doing
you've been doing five to 10K a month it
might have not been that consistent you
might have some better months than that
uh some worse months than that uh they
probably work on their own they know
they need to change uh or create a
business that's more consistent or less
reliant on them but yeah obviously that
can be overwhelming and and they're the
types of people that you find yourself
speaking to a lot of the time
is that fair yeah like I would say a lot
of people that we help are what we call
solopreneur recruiters that have some
have been in recruitment for 20 25 years
and are still doing Canada placements
themselves and they're burnt out tired
frustrated they can't exit the business
uh but they're also can't step away from
the business day to day so uh you
probably got two vehicles in terms of
like where you want to go so some times
when you start a recruitment agency you
might want to go all the way to really
scaling it up to 10 20 million and then
ex together uh obviously we know the
statistics of the chances of actually
selling a recruitment agency is pretty
much below one percent so for you to
actually get there um it's going to be
very very hard because uh I was I shared
a statistic the other day about even
just scaling an agency uh to a million
uh Plus in terms of Revenue it's pretty
much only five percent of business
owners can ever get to that Mark and
then to scale it past or businesses past
five million it's uh pretty much uh five
percent of that five percent so now
sorry one percent of that five percent
so it's it's very very difficult to get
there so a lot of people don't want to
go the full spectrum of like building an
agency to sell or they maybe realize one
year two year three year and it's very
very hard and there's a there's a
different way to do it so I think most
people that start a business as such
they want freedom they want autonomy
they want Financial Freedom for the
family and to leave a maybe a legacy
um but also to be able to work when they
want where they want uh whenever they
want and
you can do that with the recruitment
agency but if it's done correctly you
put the right systems in place the right
team the right structure
over time you can get there so yeah we
help a lot of agency owners that are
either just about starting up and maybe
six months in and then they're
struggling to get it past the 10 20K a
month Mark uh without them having to
burn to the ground working 60 70 hours a
week and then sometimes like those solar
printers that have been in the game a
long time or maybe at one two three
employees trying to hire 360 because it
keeps failing so then they're back to
just depending on themselves and maybe a
Veer we help them streamline and scale
their agency without them like I said
being involved in it like 60 something
hours a week
and that's what we're going to break
down today but I have I have let's just
start with this
what James what do we say to the cynics
that see your content See the flashy
stuff see what you're doing
and think
what what the is this all about
this this guy this isn't gonna work like
it's just one of those coaching things
they get you signed up and then yeah you
know there isn't real weight to what
they have to say or they don't actually
help me get to where I want to
um what what do we say to these to these
cynics that I'm sure you've found
yourself speaking to or you might see
the old comment which you don't let
affect you at all go now this is a load
of bollocks that this guy's uh talking
about let's just start there what do we
say to those people and then let's get
into the stuff that you teach people
yeah sure I mean look I mean I've helped
over 600 recruitment agency owners skill
their business um over the last three
nearly four years so I think um well you
tend to find people on the outside uh if
they haven't invested in themselves
before they'll tend to have a stigma
around investing in mentors courses
masterminds and look there's a lot of
people out there that are trying to sell
different things and sometimes people
don't get results so
um one thing that's very important like
I'm still around today and I get more
and more success the only way I'm
getting more and more successful is mean
I'm getting people results
um your job find out if um it was a case
of I wasn't getting any more results in
terms of coming in the program I mean
we've we've helped a lot a lot of
agencies uh get unstuck and really make
more money so
um what I would say is it doesn't matter
whether it's me or someone else but like
I would say everyone should always get a
mentor if you're in business like you
should always like find a mentor that's
three or four steps ahead of you because
having a mentor can like really
eradicate mistakes prevent you from
making some failures and get you faster
results quicker and um yeah like some
look 95 of people don't invest in
themselves that's just the way it goes
so I'm not here to convince people that
uh they should invest in themselves
that's up to them but being around more
and more successful people the one Trend
that I've spotted with Millionaires and
I was having dinner with a billionaire a
tech billionaire out in Dubai uh two
days ago and um even even then like
everyone invests on themselves
everyone's had mentors uh anyone that's
successful and the people that are set
in their ways and uh thinking they can
figure it out themselves that's fine but
what gets you from A to B doesn't get
you from B to C so there's things that
someone knows so I always like take the
wisdom Court of um mentor of mine double
chair was
if there's someone that's got more money
than you
and yes we can go down the rabbit hole
of uh success doesn't mean it's a
definition if you've got more wealth but
let's say if you're in a business we're
here to make money at the end of the day
if you if you're not making profit in
any business you don't have a business
so if we analyze people that are
successful and actually more successful
than you and made more money than you
they know something you don't know
so if you want to be arrogant and not
want to learn from them that's fine but
just know that whether you like them or
not that you you will learn something
from them so I'm always an absorber like
a sponge so if I know someone's more
successful than me I might not want to
be exactly them but I want to take at
least one percent from them can I take
some golden nuggets one or two
transitions that could help me make a
million an extra 10 million
and and that's a mindset I always go in
with learning from people is um I'm
always I'm always curious and I'm always
open to learning more and I think the
people that get the book of ones that
have invested in themselves once they
get some results
they start reading more they start
attending different events they start
get more mentorship uh naturally you're
going to be more successful like that's
just the way it goes the more you invest
in yourself I've personally found the
best investment is in yourself not
stocks knock shares uh not crypto or
anything else like to create your own
net worth when you look at people that
I've made uh eight figures and nine
figures
the their best investment is in
themselves education it's a fog with a
return on any crypto any stock any
sevens portfolio because skills and
experiences like the main two things
that you have in your life and those two
things are going to last you a lifetime
yeah I honestly I couldn't agree more so
let's break this down then so you like
to call it a hybrid agency
right
um is the terminology to use and
currently if I'm wrong uh but the
terminology that you've sort of break
this down to you might have changed it a
bit you tell me but you've got four
pillars in your hybrid agency system
you've got a system automation virtual
sourcing team and operational excellence
am I missing anything there is that is
that still up to date and correct yeah
it's pretty much like we put them in a
truck phase deliver phase systemize and
skill so like there's four key what we
call pillars in our agency blueprint
roadmap and then there's different tiers
from going from zero to 10K 10 to 30k
and then 40 to 100K plus a month
yeah cool so I asked you and preparing
for this and where I wanted to start is
like what where do you find yourself
repeating yourself the most and uh time
and time again repeating the knowledge
that you're sharing you're getting the
same questions
and I think this is really relevant
right now so why don't we just start
with having a set process to win clients
and I think this is really relevant
right now with how the Market's changed
um and uh what recruiters need to be uh
you know be world class at or be
spending more time on and you said to me
that yeah this is often where people
fall short the people that are doing 10
20 grand a month they don't have a
system to consistently be bringing in
clients because we've all been there
where like last year everyone's doing
really well we've got loads of job flow
and then obviously going into this first
half of the year that's reduced it's
like oh we need to be doing BD again
obviously your whole thing is we need to
create a system so why don't we just
start with firstly like how would you do
what makes up this client winning system
what the what are the principles to it
and what makes it up yeah great question
yeah so so boiling it down when we
reverse engineer everything back to
First principles and we look at the the
key points we need to implement first
but first we need a client map so I call
it the niche Builders but we need a
solid way of knowing that any potential
client that we could work with in our
Niche we've got that data from so we
know who the hiring manager is the
c-suite executives we've got their email
addresses we've got the LinkedIn
profiles all in a map so I would like
put in a Google sheet and that's your
master sheet okay so once that's built
you never really need to rebuild it
rebuild it again maybe you could get a
VA to top it up every six months if
there's any changes but that's the first
thing okay and then the second thing we
need in a in a truck attraction
mechanism uh enabling us to go
one-to-many with to the market to try
and get some traction with client leads
okay so we need a lead generation
machine okay so uh that could be a mix
of email automation
so with email automation it's not a case
of just okay I'm going to just plug it
into an automation tool and away we go
it's okay no like we need to make sure
that emails are hyper personalized to
the right point of contact you've got
the right type of email deliverability
you've got the correct subject lines to
get them the emails opened because half
the time they don't get opened you put
in the right context in the email to get
a reply because the number one thing for
an email campaign is not to really sell
on the email it's to get a reply because
you want to create a conversation okay
and a lot of people get the stigma
behind I don't want to automate
everything in my agency recruiters it's
a personal touch and it's human to human
interaction well yes it is but you need
leverage you've only got so much time in
the day so the number one thing you need
to do is automate the point to get to
the conversation and a lot of recruiting
agency owners don't do that and and it's
like a secondary thought because they
think oh well I've already got like
eight jobs ten jobs 12 jobs or whatever
it is but they're not really thinking
about the future because always you want
to be turning through clients to get
better and better clients the time like
naturally like when you first start off
your agency you take any any client or
pretty much anyone in the niche and you
start to realize well these guys aren't
really hiring all of the time or they're
missing me about or the little fees they
don't pay on time or they've got three
stage interview process so you
constantly need a client lead machine to
generate the other clients that might
come through in year two year three year
four and um so that's with email
automation then you've got LinkedIn
automation so like the next thing we
help you build out is a set Cadence in
terms of follow-up sequence to nurture
potential client needs through Linkedin
but obviously once you've got volume
there you need a virtual team that's
going to manage that because you can't
manage those inbox okay so then you what
we call a nurture pipeline funnel we we
put that into a different Tool uh it's
like a mini CRM that sits in your email
account that can nurture maybe responses
and yes responses
so obviously once we get a yes response
that's the that's the ultimate goal okay
so that's a like a client puts a hand up
and say yes can you can you send me the
CV or I'm interested to learn more
the next thing that most recruiters fail
to do is just obviously you pick up the
phone you give them a call and you walk
them through the requirements and then
you're talking about your terms and
maybe pitching yourself
I think it's very very important to
convert a client and walk them through a
custom experience that we call as a
signature sale system so we help you
develop a signature sales pitch deck so
it's between 18 to 24 slides and it's
actually walking that client through the
problems in the market your expertise in
the market what's going wrong with their
current hiring process and assessing
their needs and giving them a
prescription and a solution of why your
services are different so I talk about
unfair advantages in the market so we
really pitch in about this is what we do
differently within my marketing with
strategies
with automation with the way we've got
our remote Source video Outreach all
these voice note follow-ups everything
that we do differently we're packaged
together so the client can be
comfortable knowing like wow these guys
are doing something slightly different
and I understand why they're charging a
certain fee or package and then at the
end we package it together so I call
like a platinum gold silver package it
depends on how you how you customize the
pitch but you always either kitchen for
uh returned or exclusivity and then the
third part might be contingent so that's
like the the trifecta of the signature
sales system and that traditionally
normally gets eight out of 10 closes so
we should close a client 80 of the time
and I've done that I've perfected that
for the last eight years and we've had
like I think probably between every
agency we've had on board maybe 30 40
million dollars of Revenue that's
generated over time
so let's talk about let's talk about the
the first part of that because I think
we're not going to be be able to
Showcase how we're different and what we
do if we're not getting the the leads
like the leads is the actual just
complete lifeblood of of a business
right when we're in this type of uh
business so I just have one or two
things I just want to sort of draw down
here we've heard multiple times on on
this podcast so again if you're making
notes right now do you have a market map
are you consistently building uh your
Market map every single top performing
recruiter does this religiously so not
surprised that James you you started
there where you need to understand who
are the main players in in my market and
in my Niche and if I do find a a new one
that it's that information is going
somewhere and it's added to the
companies that I know I should be able
to deliver for and and solve problems
for them so we've got the market map
let's just focus on the the next two
bits because I think that's what people
will be most interested in so in terms
of let's just start with the email
automation part well right so what we're
talking here James are we are we
speccing out a shitload of candidates is
that typically what people lead them
with uh like you said the the objective
is to get a reply so like what what have
you found to be the most effective here
what have you found that
um is mainly working for the people that
you work with is it that's coming up
with a system to send out loads of CVS
and loads of candidates is it just
getting really smart with uh
personalization and talking about the
pain points that uh we know these people
have what's the key to that email part
because a lot of people use emails but
it's about doing it effectively and
people don't want to just become spammy
and and just fall into that category so
what what what's the important part
there yeah good question so like the
first thing is we don't spec a CV as
such we never put an attachment on an
email campaign so
um the number one thing that you want to
do is not use your CRM or ATS to Evers
like spec onto CV because the ATS or CRM
system and I've tested hundreds okay and
even the one we recommend inside our
program we don't recommend to use the
client Outreach using that tool so
because I've studied a lot in terms of
like inbound marketing and digital
marketing that's like the direction I've
been over the last few years and working
with a lot of Industry leaders in that
the first thing we need is
deliverability with the email so a CRM
system ATS when you put an attachment on
it it's most likely going to go into
spam or promotions okay you want it to
land in that person's inbox so the
number one tip that I would give to
everyone is make sure it's just black
and white text okay there's no
hyperlinks there's no signatures on the
email
there's nothing to click so it looks
like it's just a personal email from
James deisham okay so that gives it a
probably a 80 chance to get through all
of the spam filters and funnels to make
sure it lands in the inbox so it's not
just a case of spamming over a PDF
document or a Word document and
attachments so that's what I would say
the next thing is and then um everything
else is custom in terms of the niche we
actually inside our program I have a
hundred thousand pound a year copywriter
that works for both my companies that
comes on calls every single week inside
our coaching sessions and actually
custom creates the email campaigns with
each individual member Okay so there's
obviously a framework designed around
that in terms of the body the context
um sometimes we try and be a little bit
funny and a little bit creative and
different and then it's all about the
follow-up procedure so we looked up on
on the basics obviously we try not to
dive too much in depth because people
are listening on a podcast I can't
visually show you I would say
it's all about timing in your Market
okay so so when we look at when clients
are hiring clients are hiring probably
one to three percent of your markets
hiring at that time okay maybe five
percent at most so that means that 95 to
97 of that market when you've got your
data list is not hiring at that time so
we need to make sure we're following up
and it's all about timing to catch them
at a time when someone's handed in the
notice uh they've just had new budget to
open out a role you have to be front of
mind okay so that's like talking about
marketing 101 creating an omnipresence
in the market so that's why you need to
be all over LinkedIn you need to be
reaching out to them on LinkedIn you
need to be reaching out on email uh you
need to be doing events you need to be
sponsoring events all these different
things coming together but in terms of
the email replies let's make sure you've
got the follow-up sequence and I always
recommend six to seven follow-ups in an
email campaign and you can spread that
out over time and that means you've got
more likelihood to catch a client when
they might be looking because if you
just bus on four or five emails uh
within like let's say a four or five
week period what about in week eight or
week 16 when they actually are looking
higher than the other agencies sent them
an email
so with email campaigns it's spreading
out the follow-up sequence and making
sure you've got enough in the follow-up
there's there's 100K yeah clients that
I've won that are still clients today
that ignored every single one of my
emails until email six or email seven or
a second or third campaign in another
quarter so it is all about being
persistent and uh trying different
angles in terms of subject lines is the
number one thing to get open rates
because like if you're not getting the
email opened it's not getting read so we
need to make sure it goes to the inbox
first so that's why I was in black and
white text no links no signatures no
attachments make sure you're not using
CRM or ATS use a proper email automation
software tool and then
when that is getting delivered then
you're tweaking the the you're testing a
b variables of different uh email copy
and we change that a lot of the time I
mean we've got the you've all got the
beauty now to use chatgpt
so Chacha beauty is good in terms of you
could see whenever I see a good email or
a good code on which email that like
sort of grabs my attention I save it in
a folder with my executive assistant and
we'll go through them maybe once a month
with my copywriter and we might spin out
four or five different variations of
them okay so we'll always test different
variations so it's like signing up to
different people that are doing B2B
Outreach seeing what works and and
testing
um you can still pitch in a candidate as
search like MPC obviously that's been
going around for since the test time and
recruitment still works but I would say
but still working with with bullet
points and follow-ups and then what I
like to do on replies is we do a
customized video Outreach to the
response okay so when you're going to
maybe reply back
uh or maybe thanks for reaching out but
just not yet
doing a customized video to follow up
with the client is or potential client
is what I would recommend to nurture
them
interesting what like people are going
to be thinking this like what tool do
you get people to use typically because
my tools I would recommend something
like reply.io is good email automation
software tool
you could use something like Apollo
any any tool that is I I believe in pick
the best tool for the job okay so when
we when you come inside our program I
give you the recommendations of the
tools that we've tried and tested for
over a decade okay and there's always a
new uh kid on the Block in terms of a
shiny new object tool oh wow this is the
all-in-one solution there's no such
thing as an all-in-one solution that
does everything I've never trusted them
every every time there's a new tool out
that that incorporates LinkedIn
automation with email Automation and
finding email leads and finding phone
numbers and everything else like you
can't be the master of everything in the
software tool so I picked the software
tool that just focuses on email
Automation and that's all they do
best tool for the job
makes sense and then if we get this
right and then we'll go on to the
LinkedIn piece if we get this this
system right what do you think on
average like how many like of these
emails do you think should be going out
daily weekly if we've got this system
going repeatedly because I think that'd
be an interesting insight to people
before I think when I was in in recruit
in a recruitment business I wasn't doing
any of these emails consistent things it
was me personally writing an email like
phoning people like just a typical thing
so if we get this system right I know it
always varies but typically how many
emails then we are we probably sending
out and going out daily weekly do you
think yeah so obviously your email's got
a threshold in terms of deliverability
so if it's a brand new email domain you
need to warm up your inbox so use a tool
like warm-up inbox for example to warm
up the inbox so you know it's going to
be delivered in the Inbox and then you
want to make sure you use an email
deliverability test tool you can just go
on Google and test your email so as long
as it's like an eight or nine out of ten
deliverability then you know it's good
to go and then what I always recommend
is buying maybe three or four other
email domains you can buy as many as you
want but for example
ronaldjamesgroup.com is our website but
I've got
ronaldjamesgroup.com.net.ai.co.uk dot um
i o for example like we've got lots of
different sub domains because then you
can run different email campaigns with
the different uh providers okay so then
going from 50 a day which is normally
the threshold you can maybe push it up
100 a day but 50 is normally the the
trend you could have four domains so
that's 200 emails going out a day
now then it goes back to your client
list so have you when you're when you're
mapping out your Niche have you got
enough potential clients in your Market
Niche so I always recommend you want to
have at least
two thousand to five thousand potential
clients that you could work with over
time
so as long as you've got that that's
like that's it there's five thousand
companies two to three points of contact
so you've got either ten thousand to
fifteen thousand in a data set that
you're going to run maybe 200 emails a
day too
and then how does this how does this
differ on on LinkedIn because I feel
like do you
um I think obviously I've created my
phone wrong but dripify is something
that you use right or encourage yeah so
I've heard a lot about that but what how
how does it what differs in LinkedIn and
so we've we've done all The Upfront work
we've got the emails going we've got the
delivery deliverability we've got a six
seven step email
um you know process which is encouraging
people to reply or
um a booking a meeting with you so
you've got that going what what am I now
doing on LinkedIn then as well to
accompany that so so linkedin's slightly
different because you can't you don't
really want to put too much long copy in
the LinkedIn Outreach message because
what you tend to find is everyone knows
well a lot of people know now you're
gonna automate message Outreach so you
want to make it to come across that it's
not automated that's the number one
skill of like a LinkedIn Outreach
message is doing that so I was like
shortening our uh sequences so like two
lines three line in the copy in terms of
the link know which the best way to do
it when you're running the email
campaign you're going to run the
LinkedIn automation campaign side by
side so it means that if you're viewing
a profile of a Potential Prospect that
you've emailed they've seen that you
viewed their profile and you're like oh
okay so that's hm I understand now
there's the email so you've got a better
chance of them thinking who you are and
if they're interested they're going to
reply more
and then over LinkedIn it's all about
again follow-up sequences you might
create a journey we we normally create
on a custom Journey for for you maybe
six to ten different follow-up sequences
and ways to get replies uh whether it's
a nine word message to get a reply
whether it's a case study whether it's
pitching in a candidate whether it's
sending the loom video of a candidate uh
role and then you've got a different
strategy as well for we we call it live
leads so where there's clients are
actively hiring in your market right now
will have a different client acquisition
process to get live leads because you
need to be faster to Market with that so
you need to be more aggressive with
follow-up sequences the way you custom
Outreach with that but LinkedIn
automation the the number one goal is to
get the connection first so a lot of
people get it wrong where they're trying
to pitch either on the connection
invitation so it means it's just an
automatic Decline and they're not going
to get accepted so you've got to make
sure the profile looks strong so I mean
again back to First principles on
LinkedIn you can't just bull on a
LinkedIn automation too we've had plenty
of people before they joined us thought
LinkedIn all missions doesn't work
because they did it wrong the LinkedIn
if I wasn't good the the title the
background the profile picture the body
of like uh your LinkedIn profile that
needs to look good
then it's making sure you send the right
invitation request and
um not selling too much on the
connection message and making sure that
you're not just pitching straight away
when they connect because on automation
you could all of a sudden you get a
connection request the message one goes
you don't want to do that because then
definitely looks automated yeah
so there's different nuances that you
want to make sure you install in your
LinkedIn automation machine to make sure
that the follow-up sequences are correct
now the biggest problem most agency
owners have they come to us is if
they've done that they're overwhelmed
because then all of a sudden they've
created more work for themselves because
they've got they can't manage their
LinkedIn inbox anymore they're looking
on a weekend of in the phone and they're
like wow I need to respond to this one
and if you've got so much messages
messages and it gets messy so that's
when you when we build on the virtual
team so they're going to handle that
lead funnel inside your LinkedIn account
and the same with the email funnels and
your emails are gone because as you
scale with volume of automation it
breaks because you haven't got anyone to
manage it and you haven't got a process
or sop to make sure well this is the
process when a lead comes in or we're
going to reply on LinkedIn
hmm
yeah I'm not I'm not surprised about
that so why why don't we why don't we
cover the the virtual piece and we'll
come back to that because I also want to
because I know that's also fundamental
on our kind of acquisition funnel and
that Journey as well isn't that but I
think what people would be really
interested in
this is something I've implemented in my
own business as and has been really
effective and I think is is is missed in
in the recruitment industry so correct
me if I'm wrong here ideal client
Journey would be they get an email from
me maybe LinkedIn message might even got
a personalized video from me but
whatever the steps uh may be they get to
the point where they're like you know
what James you're being persistent it
looks like you can help you've added
value
let's have a conversation and I'll book
into your diary and we have a meeting so
this is where you obviously mentioned
around your your signature sales system
where you have a a sales deck that you
refined um and there's an opportunity to
present how you're different and what
you do
so is the typical Pro sales process
client process that you uh aim to
obviously achieve with your
um clients is like they're booking a
meeting and then that that one meeting
is when they're then pitching and
closing business is that is that the
step and then they start working on they
agree terms and they're working is that
typically the the sales process yeah
look that's the ideal scenario and
that's the the plan what we want to do
we either want to get them on Zoom as
soon as possible no never on the phone
ideally a zoom call because that's the
way you can take control of the process
because you have the signature sales
pitch deck you use it as an anchoring
point to go back because people a lot of
people are visual Learners and the way
they want to see and how we design the
presentation looks great and it walks
them through and it flows really well so
it's the only way that you can retain uh
control over the conversation to keep an
anchoring point so ideally you want to
do it over Zoom if you can do it in
person even better I know some people
that are doing different niches in the
US or whatever so it's a lot harder from
the UK so I understand that but um yeah
ideally you want to get them on Zoom
walking through the pitch and then it's
not just going through the pitch we we
also use a tool to send them a digital
proposal so we can see when they've
opened it how much time they've spent on
each part and uh to get them across the
line because it's great pitching okay
that's great send me the details but
then 50 of proposals unsigned because we
don't have a strong follow-up procedure
so making sure that we present it
correctly but also send them the correct
proposal and the right follow process to
get them to commit
hey everyone a real quick one from me
this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincere and saucebreaker because you
listen to this podcast you're able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're a growing recruitment business
you have to check out Vin Cherry who are
an all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with
saucebreaker if you want to make sure
that all of your recruiters have the
best tools on the market to stand out
and beat their competition then you have
to check out Source breaker use the link
in the show notes in the comments below
and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products okay so what are look obviously
we're not gonna uh you're not gonna go
down it's Slide by slide what's on this
slide there right but what are the pre
the principles too because I think this
is this is really valuable for people
because if you think about it and I'm
sure you hear it still now if I think
about when I was in recruitment the way
that I would negotiate terms would be on
the phone I'm trying to build
credibility trust through this initial
phone call
and you're talking about it it's very
transactional and it's it's very
difficult to Showcase your
um value and credibility via just a
phone call with a company that you know
that's hiring and you're trying to get
the best times that you possibly can and
for them to give you a chance you never
worked with them before so I think this
is this is really powerful for people
we've had someone talk about this before
that and it was really pivotal for them
so what it what are the principles that
should go into your sales presentation
obviously you've really refined this but
what what are the non-negotiables that
should be on this presentation that
people can take away and at least try
them to put together themselves yeah
good question so so we we don't just
have one proposal so as you scale the
seven Figures it's not about doing a
pitch deck uh it's about winning
business that's like 10 15 50 placements
a year so like I've got a pitch Deck
with a a big billion pound Bank in the
UK that we won we placed over 60
employees there and built on the full
team over two year period it was worth
over 750 000 and uh that pitch deck is
like 78 slides it took me a long long
time because we had to go through a full
c-suite Executives I had to go to the
headquarters in Edinburgh there was 20
people around the room asking me
different strategies and that was all
around inbound marketing strategies so
building out career page websites for
them video social media uh Tech events
to to capture the audience so as you
ascend your agency there's a different
type of signature sales pitch check I
would say that you can really package up
pretend and the outsourced in Source
model uh and that works really well
especially in today's market if like
actually looking after all of the
recruitment Services of the company once
you've established in a niche that's the
next level but we're talking about the
basic just simple uh signature sales
pitch deck that we use the first thing
is Introduction so you want to you want
to face the problems head on so we we
have a slide that will be say your the
problems that you're facing right now so
I understand you Hashem because you may
be struggling to higher XYZ candidates
at the moment because you haven't got
inbound systems to get them uh the
business is struggling to retain this
type of level of candidate because of
XYZ you may be fallen behind on projects
because of these issues uh and like five
or six areas of the problems that
they're facing so they get that you get
the market okay that you understand
salaries have increased by 30 and here's
the trend for example
and then you recognize and look this is
what I do is traditional methods do not
work so I'll say like job boards are in
fast decline uh developers don't openly
apply for jobs because they're not
actively looking average developers
getting maybe 50 to 100 messages every
single week on LinkedIn
um cold calling developers head it
doesn't work company adverts are not
really getting any responses so I'm
recognizing with them that the
traditional methods of recruitment
aren't working anymore we need a
different solution
so then we'll walk them through like
well how our system helps to implement
in their business to not only attract
but also retain good employees so we
talk about focusing on the passive we
call it a passive digital automation
funnel so we'll say look we know 80 of
the developers in the market are not
actively looking for a job
but they would be open to move if all
things were right and these this is the
content nurture engage convert strategy
that we do and then we'll show all of
the different tools we use our virtual
sourcing team uh all of the email
campaigns the way we do events and
webinars and everything else and how we
our database has got everything in the
market like a lot of different
strategies and unique Point tracking
open system of emails so we know when a
candidate is potentially looking to move
for example
so we will show them like the marketing
piece of like what we do differently to
a traditional agency because I like
saying that we're more a hybrid agency
we're more digital marketing recruitment
agency so we're using leveraging
technology tools systems uh remote teams
and uh clever strategies to engage with
candidates
then we're walking through I call it a
10-point metric scoring system of like
how we analyze a candidate before we
present to them uh the areas that we
focus on in the business so like
Authority automation like making sure
that database is correct the events
webinars like career sites
and then the type of clients that we
work with and a bit of Storytelling so
walking them through I'd always create a
custom slider to around a company that
was similar to them that we helped and
they were stuck and had this problem and
this was a solution and this is where we
placed five or ten developers over the
air for example
so they they can resonate with that so
like the closer you've got a company
that was similar to them the better
then uh I talk about building a mode
around the agency and like trying to get
control off the market so we build uh
what are called Talent pools for uh
their business so we take them offline
from an email and we've got like a tool
that we use with Trello to actually send
candidates and walk them through the
floor
so I'll try and get my client to use
that so that means that other agencies
are just that are sending traditional
emails via CV this clients used to use
in Trello now and I communicate with
them in slack for example so we move an
interview process they can visually see
everything uh and they can move them
through a process a lot quicker people
try and use their own ATS it's got this
plugin look it's never going to work
client's not going to use that but
that's why we built something that was a
tool that a lot of definitely a lot of
tech companies use
we created we walk through like the the
hiring plan so we create a best full
plan for them we'll walk them through
the end-to-end hiring process so we'll
show them a visual map of exactly what
happens day one with requirements
project kickoff to ignite in the passive
Talent funnel to the talent pool to help
building their brand in the in the
market as well because us as recruitment
agency owners and a lot of agency owners
should use this is you should leverage
your brand your brand in in your niche
is a lot bigger than the company that's
hiring for that Talent
so for example if a company in the
Northeast is hiring a developer the
likelihood of them getting them using us
is going to be 10 times more likely
because we're collectively on our
LinkedIn profiles we've probably got
like 100 000 connections engaged like on
news feeds Etc so we help them build
their brand and like create more
awareness in the market for their
company
uh yeah so we're walking through hand
and hiring process the delivery plan
and then we package up the services at
the end and bundle it together off like
I said exclusive uh sorry retained
exclusive or contingent
two things I love about that thank you
for breaking that down
two things one as you all know
oftentimes the perception of what
recruiters do isn't the real the reality
of it so all those things that you just
said then
is going to Showcase when you get to the
and this is how we work these are our
terms this is all that they've obviously
gone on a journey to actually understand
what the happens like when they
work with them right which oftentimes is
difficult to do when you're on a phone
call saying no we worked 20 that's what
we do and it can and like you've taken
on that whole journey first thing second
thing what I really like about this is
what you're teaching people to do for
their own business they then can use
those systems and approaches with their
clients exactly right and I think that's
super smart you're practicing What You
Preach you're doing what you do for
yourself but then you're able to then uh
offer that and speak to companies it
will be a point of difference and it
will be uh something that hopefully can
achieve obviously a better results more
quickly and in a more effective way so I
think that that's that's super smart so
why don't we move this on to then like
the the the sourcing P um the sort of
Outsourcing uh piece and the remote
piece because that's also fundamental so
uh again currently if I'm wrong it
sounds like I think when we lasted an
interview we spoke a bit about remote
teams and stuff it seems like you've had
obviously so much experience over the
years in dealing with remote people and
having
um Outsource uh resources that you can
use so where
where typically is it like when we're
trying to go in this journey of
implementing some of these things
where is it that we really need to
commit to trying to get the Outsource
um the um the on the virtual resource
right is it really fundamental that we
have the virtual resource system working
for managing the the leads and managing
that part because that's really
difficult to do in your own and then is
it also absolutely fundamental when it
comes to the sourcing element and have
people always be creating short lists
and these types of things are they the
two key areas on on the virtual front
yeah it's a good question so so it's
split into two parts now so first you've
got what we call like a virtual team
that is handling uh maybe from the
Philippines that handles all of admin
all of the lead funnel all of the
follow-up sequences okay so that's just
like
the first thing you need to do is get
you your VA system in place so you can
stop doing tasks that are worth ten
dollars to fifty dollars an hour okay so
we can we can systemize that we can
create a step-by-step process for that
so all you're doing is speaking high
quality clients doing the pictures
winning the business on it off to your
delivery team that's an ideal solution
for a business owner
the second thing and the most important
thing now that's been the biggest shift
and this is probably the best training
that I've developed for
um probably the last three years is what
I call the marketing sourcing system so
this is where you get marketing sources
from different countries that are doing
video Outreach they're doing voice not
follow-up they're doing all of the
marketing in your business they're doing
all of the social media and actually
sourcing candidates replying backwards
and forwards nurturing candidates in
your Niche to then book qualified calls
into yours or your recruitment
Consultants diary so all they're doing
is got a day worth of calls for
qualified candidates for their live jobs
they do in the interview uh kind of the
interview over the phone qualification
sending CVS get an interview feedback
closing deals because once you get that
system run these are the hardest things
to get going because it's great if you
hire talent and some people try and hire
two 360 recruiters then all of a sudden
they haven't built for three months so
it's costing too much money it went back
to just doing it themselves because they
were building 20K a month themselves if
I had to recruiters and now they're
pretty much losing money so and then the
struggle to get past that that's because
they're trying to scale with a business
that is going to fail it's not like on
House of Cards haven't built the systems
to generate clients enough volume for
not just them for the rest of the team a
consistent way to get them either
exclusive or return because you want
exclusivity as a minimum ideally because
it gives you more time to fill the role
so it gives you your team time to
deliver as long as you can deliver
within 21 days or 30 days there's no
reason why you can't get them exclusive
like most clients would prefer to work
with 1.0 to two Talent Partners they
don't want many others
um so the marketing sourcing system is
the next thing that you want to get
right along with the virtual team so
that's that they can be both remote so
they're not in the office they can run
itself and the the they're quite cheap I
mean I reverse engineer the modeling for
uh the payment structure for the
sourcing team so a lot of people inside
our program have hired three or four of
these sources and they've never had to
do any sourcing again so they aren't
they their own LinkedIn inbox all of the
time they're not having to worry about
generating candidates anymore and each
employee depending on where we hire them
from is around about a thousand dollars
to fifteen hundred uh dollars a month in
terms of cost but they bring in a 10x
orio a thousand X Roi you pay them a
thousand dollars they bring in a ten
thousand dollar fee like we it goes back
to investing in yourself at the stock
compared to stocks and crypto like if
you've got a model where if you if you
hire one person and they're gonna give
you a 10x Roi or 5x Roi why wouldn't you
double that and triple that
so it gives you a really agile model
that you can that you can build on
look it sounds great
right and
I've had my own experience like I I use
a VA
you you tell me where people maybe over
complicate it or have the wrong
perception of thinking that getting to
the point you describe this that's never
going to work like they're not going to
be as good quality as James says or like
it's just gonna be way more difficult
than you make out from my experience I
feel like the really upfront work which
you which then pays dividends to get to
the point which you described is all of
that upfront work of mapping out the
systems when this happens to do that
this is what a good candidate looks like
this is this this is that and it's all
those steps that that's the part that is
painful and you have to do but if you
get really good at making it really easy
for James to follow step by step when
this happens do that when this happens
do that then you've got a way higher
chance of this this type of approach
working but you tell me like the people
often think oh yeah I'm gonna get to the
point where James says but then have
nothing like documented no like Steps
thing and it's it's just crazy to think
that you can get someone to a point
where they're doing good quality working
and getting the the types of um people
in front of you and doing one thing to
do like what like what are the
assumptions that people get wrong here
and where are the things that people
often fall short of to get the system
going well one they've never done it
before so they're trying to learn it
themselves whilst being a recruiter and
Runner recruitment agency so the chances
of that being successful are very very
slim which it goes back to go and find
someone that's already proven that it
works learn from them and Implement a
lot faster and you're going to stick to
it and you're going to get better
results like it's it's very simple
because as a recruitment agency only you
have not got enough time like the last
thing an agency only want to do is I'm
hiring a VA I've trained I've told them
to do this and I haven't done it it
hasn't worked out and then they quit so
you're either going to be prepared to
put in extra work which is an extra 10
hours per week to train them build the
Sops the follow-up sequences get it
dialed in because it's going to take six
months to dial in if you're doing it
yourself six to 12 months because you're
gonna have to learn the hardware because
you haven't you can't you can't cheat it
or you paid someone that's already been
there done that and can just replicate
the steps and plug it in so for instance
for our Marketing System uh which was a
good question you asked about it all
sounds great we give six months Training
Academy with all of our sources so when
you come into our program and we help
you we can help you find train and
manage that marketing Source because we
perfected the model and our head of
marketing will train them common cause
every single week help them with loom
Outreach LinkedIn follow-ups uh message
sequences things that are working to get
candidates over the line so that takes
the weight off the agency owner's
shoulders because they haven't got five
to ten hours a week to sit with a
marketing saucer to say no don't do the
video that way don't message these type
of candidates that way and follow-up
sequences so it's either like either
either trading time or you've got money
those are the only two resources so if
you've got money you pay to buy that
time back or if you've got time go and
invest in the extra 10 hours a week
yourself to to train up the sourcing
team and try and figure it out
uh that's what I would say is like
there's there's Evo Hardware which is
the longer we're trying to figure it out
yourself or you would just it doesn't
matter whether it's me or someone else
that understands how to build out
virtual teams and models uh that's what
I would do if I was if I was at an
agency owner that was at 10 20K a month
I would invest some of that money to try
and get there a lot quicker because if I
can figure that out three to six months
shorter period and I'm building 20K a
month if that's 120 000 pounds that I
can make more money on
so but sometimes people don't think of
things that way in terms of time but
time is finite money is infinite
so just just grant another question
before uh as you come to the end here
I'll ask you a couple more things but
just grabbing a question are these
people messaging people from like
Hisham from Ronald James his message you
or is it typically is it typically set
up where it's like James the founder is
missing you how how have you typically
approached that what does that typically
look like yeah so with the marketing
sourcing system it's it's the person so
I ideally we'll have like a most likely
it's a female in this world because
they're good at social media marketing
and they want their career so we'll
always pick people that have got social
media marketing skills and they're the
ones that I do in the video aren't reach
so they're it's there it's their
LinkedIn profile and they're the ones
that are mastering the sourcing and all
they do is the sourcing so they live
breathe the candidate in that market
that's it and then they're passing on
the calls booked into the recruiters
diary
because recruiters don't do that they
don't want to do that like a skilled
recruiter is good at speaking candidates
over the phone do an interview
qualification calls and closing deals
getting them to Source correctly on
LinkedIn they'll mess around on the news
feed for a lot of time like in different
posts making shoot with comments or
whatever it is in the Inbox and they
will they will go to the shortest cut
route to success so if they can just
email three top candidates get two
replies get two CVS job done like but
that's good they can still do that but
it's the rest of the market they're not
going to outreach to or they're going to
video Outreach to all of the rest of the
like 120 on the shortlist probably not
because I haven't got time because I
work in maybe eight jobs 10 jobs
okay we're out for time here yeah just
for another is that right I'm good yeah
all right so I think that so look so
much value here and you've really gone
into detail and communicating things
really really well so I think this is
really going to get people thinking but
then I think when I was asking you
around
what are the common light bulb moments
that you find people you work with have
I think the other thing we haven't
spoken about here so let's speak about
it is I think you said to me never learn
the skill of owning a business so for me
that sounds like a mindset piece or like
I don't know what like how fundamental
is really shifting your mindset here if
I'm in that hamster wheel of 10 20 grand
a month last month then it was five
grand month the month before what what
sort of mindset and different framings
and different perspectives have you
found yourself have to help people
arrive at or create for people to get to
a point where they're earning more money
they're working less in the business
more on the business or doing more the
things that they enjoy and and they're
able to get from that six to seven
figure what are the mindset shifts in
order to do that yeah well everything
goes back to mindset so like spend a lot
of time strengthening it because it's
the only thing that will ensure that you
don't break when you have bad months or
recessions come and everything else it's
your man
stays strong and I would say like what
gets you from six figures as a recruiter
and a solopreneur will not get you the
seven figures you need to become a
different version of yourself
so uh I would definitely say like one
thing that we work on inside the program
is turning uh Hisham from version 1.0 to
2.0 so who do I need to become in order
to get to where I want to get to is very
very important and some people might say
to horn or fluff but like when I look
back over myself over the last five to
seven years into where I am now like
with the network network of eight
figures and multiple businesses and and
live in my dream uh look it wasn't
always like that it was a struggle I was
in a small office with my brother
starting up trying to hustle starting to
grind having to go out and meet clients
every single week wins them repeat for
four or five years but I did that whilst
trying to understand how can I not keep
doing this again in terms of like how
kind of systemize how can I automate I'm
always thinking how can I remove myself
from the business a little bit more just
a little bit more and a little bit more
but a lot of people that
are stuck at the 20K it is come down to
mindset so it's fear belief and it's not
known what they don't know so it's the
unknown and this like scaling a business
is this like the scariest thing you'll
ever do in your life and it's going to
put you in places of like being
extremely uncomfortable and you have to
be comfortable being uncomfortable but
if you can learn from others that have
already been there to make you feel a
little bit more comfortable and even a
community like your community or someone
else's community that you can share
ideas with and ask questions and we
confirm things of like limited beliefs
in your mindset or negative thoughts
then it's going to be a little bit
easier so I would say just working on
yourself every single day in terms of
personal development I've reading books
listening podcasts like they do now
and uh yeah finding a mentor is like one
of the biggest things that changed my
life for sure and I consistently learn
and pay to learn all of the time but um
a lot of things that people hold
themselves back at 20 cares they want to
do everything themselves and I don't
worry I was there I need to send that
LinkedIn no one can use my LinkedIn
account or what if I send a message to a
candidate that I shouldn't have sent to
or reach on to a client that already
knows me and it's going to look
automated all of these false perceptions
are made up in our heads like why why is
that then do you think because I'm not
surprised that that why is why is it
that you think people latch on and hold
on to no one should be doing this or I
need to be doing that why is that just
ego in control like that one of the
hardest things as a business owner is
delegating like and that's one thing I
help business owners do is helping them
and forcing them to delegate and the bit
the more they delegate the better the
feel but it's it's lack of control it's
like driving the car with no steering
wheel and like driving in a Tesla and
trusting it to automate and drive of
itself it's because you've been used to
doing it yourself for so long it's very
very hard and unwiring that part of your
brain so that's what I'm saying like
people that have been in the business
like 20 years in recruitment it's even
harder for them to like and hats off
we've got a lot of people in the program
that we've helped transform after 20
years and they're like James I wish I
knew this like five ten years ago but it
comes to a part where like sometimes
green fresh people or maybe we could
have just start an emergency
if they can do this from first
principles and start off from day one
it's gonna be a lot easier the people
that are further and further further
down the line it's harder and harder to
convince them to do things a different
way and um but they'll come to a point
where they're hitting a brick wall and
they're thinking when when they're
seeing people that are only I've just
interviewed Sam Sammy which is going to
be a good podcast that's on my YouTube
channel soon as this comes out and he
was a financial advisor that that didn't
have a clue about recruitment joined the
program started whilst working his job
and now he's doing a million a year in
his agency
80k months and then now he was taking a
holiday cruise like for five weeks with
his little daughter and his misses and
the reason why he did that he just he
was just green you just absorbed every
single bit of information and
implemented it it didn't have another
voice in his head questioning well this
isn't going to work because we tried
this before remember Hisham uh in a
different way so
and then what you'll tend to find is
people that are stuck at 20K months 20
years in why are you still stuck at 20K
months when someone else is at 80k
months there must be something wrong
with my mindset or I should be just open
to trusting in a process that I just
don't I clearly I've got to where I've
got to A to B which is great but like I
said before it gets you from b2c it's a
different process different strategy
different system you need to learn maybe
from someone else to show you the way
because you can't see around those
Corners you haven't been through
yeah no I love it look I've I've always
whenever we spoke always respected the
journey that you've been on and how
you're helping people I speak to a lot
I've literally had like free
conversations this week with
solopreneurs uh who
you know uh lonely it's challenging they
don't have a community they they make
decisions and think was that the right
decision should I be doing that or
should I be doing this and as you'll
know most people start their own
recruitment company and what they then
do is right I'm going to start my own
recruitment company and do it the same
but different and this is what I'm gonna
do that's different so a lot of these
recruitment companies and when people go
on that real quick entrepreneurial
Journey oftentimes just do what they've
always done but maybe 10 15 20 better
so I think for the right person what
you're doing
really is going to open people's minds
and get them thinking about how they can
build a recruitment business in an
entirely different way which they've
probably never experienced before when
being employed and working for
recruitment companies so I think for the
for the right person for the right
entrepreneur who has the you know the
open mindness and wants to build a
business that they're not working in all
the time and is profitable I think this
is something that um is going to help a
lot of people which is why I wanted to
really dig into this uh with you today
because there's a lot of lonely
shadowpreneurs who are unsure if what
they're doing is Right would probably
love to spend more time with their
family we'd love to earn more money but
think that in order for them to do that
they have to do what they did at their
old employer which was hire people and
these things so I totally get it you've
hit the nail on the head and listen I I
remember where I was in their position
so I was a recruiter working at a S3
style recruitment agency at Nigel Frank
International front group a great
company and I learned a lot from them
but one thing I knew I didn't want an
agency like this because I like imagine
me leaving there and that's like worth
two 300 400 million and it's a big
Empire I can't replicate their model
just me and so like I knew from day one
I remember I still remember to this day
I was in Cafe near in Newcastle I put my
notice in I was getting legal letters
and all sorts and I was like in 20K of
debt because I took out a loan to pay
for my business I was opening up my
laptop and day one I was like right well
what Market am I going to do how do I
understand what Niche I'm gonna do oh
well they did a Salesforce I can maybe
do that and try and do that like there
was no strategy I had no one to speak to
I was getting anxiety I was under
pressure I was watching all of these
self-development things but I was like
well I don't know the how if all I know
is to come in get your boards make cold
calls uh be around the team and try and
like make some placements and um yeah
it's a lonely road there's a and back
then I didn't there was no one on the
market that could help you with a plan
the only person there was uh was James
Khan so I had plenty of interviews with
him and he he obviously asked to invest
in my business and uh for me I decided
against that and um I wanted 100 control
and I figured it out a different way in
a different path because a lot of people
that are setting up their agency now
they're modeling the company they came
from and if they've came from a company
that is above 50 employees or 20 30
employees it's probably not the business
one they want because if they look at
the recruitment or business owner that
they work for are they taking six
holidays a year are they spending a lot
of time with the family are they in the
office all of the time eight to ten
hours because I wouldn't want to be that
owner and most people that are setting
up they want freedom
but they're building a business on a
Model where they're the business owner
the Whipple didn't have freedom
so they're trying to emulate that and
then they haven't got the financial
resource to do it then they're trying to
learn how to be an entrepreneur how to
grow a business how to build the systems
and attract Talent no one's going to
work for you if you haven't got
Financial backend a track record and
some really good clients and some
systems so that's why I help you build
out the candid attraction piece the
client attraction piece so then at least
when you're hiring
you've got a better chance to hire
someone good because they're coming into
something that's slightly different that
they can maybe make more money whilst
just working nine to five as opposed to
working it to let back in the day when I
used to have to do that
so look how um if I'm listening to this
right now I've been hovering at that 10
20K a month Mark I might have had a few
bigger months I might be on my own there
might be just two three of us uh and
what I've learned today is really
interesting but there's a there's a lot
there's one thing listen to this and
there's another thing being committed
Financial investment emotional
investment Community all these things so
how how do people typically end up being
able to speak to you or find out if any
of your products can can help their
business or be a good fit yeah awesome
so they can go to agencyblueprint.com
there's you can book a call uh through
them so maybe you'll put a book called
link with one of our team look we will
at least give you a plan we'll we'll see
if we can help you or not because we
don't take on everyone I'm not going to
take on anyone with no recruitment
experience at all for example and very
rare in those cases unless they've got
big commitment and they've got a good uh
Network in their own Niche and uh yeah
we'll see if we can we can we can help
you and uh so agency blueprint.com
obvious say I've got my book that's come
on called automatic clients
sorry automatic recruitment agency so I
would get automatic clients in Canada so
it should go to automatic
recruitmentagency.com where I've pretty
much put everything that we discussed in
today's session in ubook you can you can
go away implement it yourself uh yeah
and like I said I mean
95 of people don't invest in themselves
whether it's me or someone else all I
would say is like go and get a mentor
because they will know something you
don't know and they will help you get
there a little bit quicker and help you
from not making fundamental mistakes
because 95 businesses fail within five
years so try and make sure that you're
not on that 95 and uh but in yeah like
hopefully that uh episode was was useful
and and I'm happy to answer any
questions uh if anyone wants to reach on
to me on LinkedIn or um on our website
and then I'm more than happy to help
sometimes I go live maybe once once a
month on webinars on LinkedIn uh but
yeah like it was interesting you you
said at the start of the session about
probably a lot of people have maybe seen
me advertise on LinkedIn and that type
of stuff and uh
it might annoy you sometimes but one
thing I learned from one of my mentors
Grant Cardone is like
all like feedback is good feedback in
terms of making an omnipresence in the
market and you I need to I need to be
seen so like
sometimes on the outside it might come
across a bit arrogant or whatever it's
never my intention it's just a case of
you've always got to look at people that
are maybe ahead of you in in whatever
area of business in life and they must
be doing something right because you
can't just suddenly like for instance
like the amount of money we spend on ads
and everything analysis just to to go
more in a bigger Market but there might
be something that I can help you with
and a bit of wisdom and a bit of things
that you might learn and you might take
80 from someone else uh and that's good
too like there's plenty of mentors I've
had I've took 10 from them 10 from them
but you are your own person so that's
one thing that I want to to get away it
might not be just one Mentor you have
you're going to have many mentors over
your career
no I think no absolutely and and I just
think like for me why I why I'm curious
why I respect uh what you're doing and
the things that you share is for me
you're practicing What You Preach like
if I end up on a call with one of your
team because I've seen your LinkedIn ad
or as a message or as one of the emails
like you I I think it's so important
when you're in the education business
like you are a coaching business you
you've got to practice what you preach
there's nothing more worse than
you know taking a life advice from
someone that hasn't trodden the path
that you want to try the nun yeah uh so
look James keep doing your thing
um I think it's great what you're doing
it for the right person I think it's um
a great help because I've spoken to
individuals that have worked with you
and
um it's been absolutely pivotal for them
so keep being you James appreciate it
and thanks for uh coming on the Pod
thanks sisham and thanks for everyone
for listening thank you so much for
listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode